[Musique]
le gouvernement Macron promet une
réforme de de la retraite sur la
retraite avec un allongement de l'âge de
départ à la retraite de 60 à 64 ans et
une augmentation du taux du nombre de
cotisations la majorité des salariés
sont opposés à l'augmentation de l'âge
de départ de la retraite tant que Macron
n'a pas retiré ce projet de loi nous on
continuera à mobiliser l'ensemble des
salariés alors proposer des journées
d'action de grève
[Musique]
au départ à 60 ans avec en financement
intégré par notamment des la suppression
de certaines exonérations de cotisations
par le respect de l'égalité femme homme
au travail les femmes alors je se valeur
c'est 5,5 milliards des cotisations qui
rentrent dans les caisses donc la
quasiment la moitié du déficit est
résolu
on a énormément de camarades qui sont
sollicités par des salariés certains
dans certains endroits c'est pas mal les
cadres qui demandent comment on fait
grève j'ai jamais fait grève de ma vie
mais là trop c'est trop il faut c'est
pas possible il faut se mettre en grève
pour dire que qu'on ne veut plus de
cette réforme alors communiquer inter
syndicale qui vient d'être établi
actuellement signé par la FSU 78 par
fo78 solidaire 78 et l'Union des
étudiants Yves Linois plus la CGT et des
Yvelines bien entendu la discussion
n'est pas fermée on propose de
rencontrer les autres organisations
syndicales mercredi soir prochain pour
voir comment on travaille le
revendicatif dans le département sur
cette question là
[Musique]